I just gave you 100 million dollars
tax-free what do you do what state am I
in wherever you want to be where do you
want to go that's free those tax free
tax free you can do anything you want
100 million dollars what a republican
ass response person what state am I
that's Red foreign
what would I do with a hundred million
dollars and why would you give away none
of it
because it's mine you gave it to me what
am I doing 100 million I would probably
I'd probably set up everyone that I love
which is my family no my parents just
people that my family my parents and my
wife and her parents you'll figure it
out I'd lace up some people in my family
does Bobby get a piece he's like nope
series everybody Bobby would not get a
dime okay I would lace up everyone make
sure everyone's taken care of yeah and
then I would go uh uh I I don't even I
couldn't even I don't even have a
creative answer for you because that
would be that's a scary I don't know
what that would do to me would you stop
acting
stop doing bad [ __ ] no comedy
oh stand up yeah probably what about
would you
because I don't even know I don't even
know how what can you talk I think that
I think the the misstep here is your
life would you don't you don't even know
how to operate with it if someone
dropped 100 million what am I doing with
it it's like what well otherwise it
would be like well I don't really I
would just keep living my life the way I
am doing it then why would I need it
then that would be the question what
would it do for you well maybe you want
to buy your mom a real car
rich guy bully no the question the
philosophical question is what would I
do what would you need it for now well
ask him what he got his parents for
Christmas
for Christmas I got them uh season
tickets to the ballet are you really
yeah don't call me ever again
bro you thought I was gonna say he
abandoned them to go to Columbia and
have a great time on Christmas and Costa
Rica okay you got them season tickets to
the ballet yes that's fire damn that's a
decent guy I know I know I know where
you came from man that's nice I gotta
get my dad chicken wing cards on the
class level it was a little different
the way we grew up somewhere if I'm like
Dad you want pictures to the ballet
season tickets to the WingHouse what's
going on when you went in Hollywood
I like the ballet
no I don't know what I would do with 100
million you don't have there's nothing
you would buy no place you would go is
there a place you've always wanted I
would travel a bunch but I but I have
the ability to do it now I'm blessed to
know I can do it now so that's kind of I
really mean this from a philosophical I
don't know if I'd want it because you
have I don't know what I would do with
it because you'd be like why do I have
all this [ __ ] money I would have to
give it to people I love and then go
well now I have a responsibility to
invest it in things like uh that would
grow a future of that now you have to
[ __ ] now your responsibility now you
have to graze a community now you have
to help out people in your communities
around you can't just have it and use it
it's a worthless what are you gonna do
with it by yourself
you get all that money you're gonna have
to like
start to grow something with it you're
gonna have to start a company that helps
people out you're gonna have to you have
to reinvest that in the community that's
a big job in and of itself you don't
have to do anything yeah yeah you do
though yeah you're saying morally you
should no yes but also what otherwise
it's useless I'm saying no morally I
think it's a great idea also it's
useless if you don't you put it so what
does it provide it provides Freedom
right but you have enough Freedom
already you're blessed enough for you
already he said me right now yeah I'm
okay right now I'm happy why you can't
stop doing what you're doing I would
never stop doing what I'm doing but
that's what I'm saying I don't know I
don't know if you would because you
don't have the money to again I would
probably I would probably try to put it
to work
you know what I mean what about an
Indulgence like is there a certain thing
that you've always wanted to do with
your wife and you guys go [ __ ] it let's
just go we we would travel a [ __ ] load
we would go to places we've never been
but outside of that I don't you can't go
to all those places now but so yes my
point is yeah I don't want the 100
million oh I don't know what I would do
it I really don't know I think at some
point too much nothing huh but I enjoy
it I like what I have right now I don't
even know what I would I'm not a [ __ ]
materialist I don't need a lot of it but
there was a time when you didn't have
all this that you have now yeah but dude
when I got a house yeah when I finally
could afford to buy a house I was so
[ __ ] happy I was like I've never sat
in it and gone I need a bigger [ __ ]
house I wanted that guy's house don't
give a [ __ ] I like my [ __ ] live in
the same neighborhood as Avatar so yeah
it's probably a pretty big house this
house is a little bit nicer than mine
but it's just I don't care I don't I
never had that thing where I'm like I
need I need I need I want I want what
about what about with the cars or
something I have the car that I like I
like my car now I've seen his car it's a
nice car but I don't need I don't it's
like I don't need a Ferrari I don't need
I don't want not about need more about
like there's something that you've
always liked always enjoyed and finally
you're in a position where you can buy
it well I'll tell you financially
something that I'm that I'm trying to
make a possibility is for my 40th
birthday I want to take my family and
her family on a jet to Hawaii perfect
done now we have a thing but I mean
that's you know what about that home in
Colorado maybe remember you were
thinking about that yeah that'd be nice
maybe but also I don't need it I'm
saying this is the problem is I don't
need the money so I'm saying I don't
it's an awesome blessing but then you're
like well what am I gonna do it dude
have you ever seen the thing about the
people that win the lotto they're
miserable they'd have no idea what to do
with all of it yeah but think about
who's playing the lotto it's like
you're not going to see them at the
ballet I'm just saying they're going
from zero to 100 million you're going
from Imagine Millions to 100 I'm going
from a good amount of money to way too
much money right also 100 million a lot
of athletes make that it's not like
you're in somewhere you're in rarified
air but it's not like your friends it's
not billions where there's like 50 of
them on Earth none of my friends make
100 million there are people that we
know that I've seen you in pictures with
oh yeah yeah athletes that it looks like
you're friendly with that have contracts
that are worth a hundred million and I
will tell you some of those friends that
have that kind of money yeah they don't
do anything different than I do so then
there you go but my point is then they
just have a lot of money so now you're
like at some point what are you going to
do with all that money spoil your
friends and spoil your family there you
go spoil your family I like when you
said take the Jet and you take all your
friends on this crazy day that's what
I'd love to be able to do just spoil the
people in our family with me to go do
something private pay for all of it and
be like look at that [ __ ] give them cool
opportunities they never got like you
have a cousin of yours that you really
believe in they don't have the you know
funding to you know learn this [ __ ]
instrument that they really want to and
it's like here yeah this summer you go
to the camp learn your [ __ ] guitar
yeah like that but then I guess what I'm
saying is deeply truly philosophically
you it you are responsible to do
something positive with that money
otherwise you will be super sad and
[ __ ] really alone this is a cool
guilt thing that I'm getting from you
that I didn't I didn't predict but this
is I've always had I've I can't
was free
I swear to God I believe so I'm so
with money I'm so scared of money I
don't like of losing it I just don't
like it I don't like it I don't like the
idea the Catholic thing I worked so hard
to get it and I'm also like I don't like
the weird pressure it puts on you
because you feel like if you have it
money is I'm imagining you feel like
it's kind of dirty that that's usually a
religious feeling it won't matter more
than others feels oh a guild complex
with money I've always had sure we grew
up with that because we didn't grow up
with a ton of money so it was always
like you know halves Have Nots type of
[ __ ] like those guys do that kind of
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah that's always
a phrase that was like oh yeah well the
country club guys yeah you know so I've
always had that in my bloodline can you
have an insecurity of being one of those
people that your family maybe grew up
being critical of and yes a little but
also because I just um
there is an inherent piece of you that
was raised a certain way that you're
like I'm not that guy no we all have it
yeah I don't [ __ ] you're like I don't
do those especially going growing up in
like strict class structures like my
mom's from Scotland and like she grew up
like you know don't think you're better
than the community well that was what
you think you are yeah yeah my mom would
always see like when we were kids in
Chicago even going to La probably there
was some I'm sure sentiment nobody likes
La in Chicago no exactly oh who does he
think he is trying to be an actor right
who does he think he is and if you're
going to LA to become an actor or
comedian I want to say to you right now
good luck I love you you're gonna have
to win the lottery you're gonna have to
win the lottery no I
I said I I applaud anybody that does
that I left Chicago I'm happy it worked
what did your family think when you left
they were they knew that I was going to
try it yeah but like the likelihood of
failure is probably high for most people
that leave so my parents are probably
like I hope it works I hope you don't
get your heart broken right that's kind
of that's back to this feeling with
money because I'm sure a lot of people
share a similar feeling as you which is
like you you want to acquire it but at
the same time you have this distaste for
it because maybe it could turn you into
somebody that you don't want to be
just maybe it'll maybe it'll it will
complicate things more even with your
family just like and it does complicate
100 but also makes a lot of things very
easy can do yeah like it provides
security it depends on how good you are
about the way you the the level of
relationship respect that you have with
it some people are really good about it
so you understand their level and
balance with it yeah never have been
able to the biggest problem I've seen is
compare you're always comparing yourself
to the circle around you and then once
you grab levitate a level two nine
figures you start looking at the other
nine figures and being like well he's
got X y's everyone's gonna you're always
gonna look up
that's a terrible place to be yeah for
me it's more like
if you told me right now I could
continue doing what I'm doing for the
rest of my La life yeah and just just
make the same amount of money I've been
making or continue to sign I'll sign in
blood I would take that over that
[ __ ] 100 million any day of the week
so you told me sign in blood today what
you made last year yeah or the year
before even if you can make that for the
rest of your life till I die well
inflation inflation yeah
you can handle this
responsibility you know how to handle
the responsibility of the money that you
have right now yeah what I'm
understanding from you is that
responsibility is increased a hundred
times or whatever the [ __ ] it is when
you have 100 million and taking on that
100 I don't want a responsibility would
be too uncomfortable for you that's a
really interesting could it also be
that's true I feel like you you said
it's true because you said what I've
made now you feel like you've earned
what you made enough you were blessed
with 100 million you might not feel like
you earned it
yeah I'm proud of earning the dollars
I'm proud of like doing shows trying to
make fans happy and earning your money
that is that how you feel clean about
you're like dude I [ __ ] I did the
thing for you yeah we did the thing
together that's great you know I sold
you the product you like the product but
like when you get and I snow people they
get grandiose amounts of money for doing
almost nothing and I don't think you
give a [ __ ] about it I don't think they
give any [ __ ] about it any of my
friends that have a [ __ ] absurd
amount of money or even people I know
are met they don't give a [ __ ] about it
you can't it's it's it doesn't matter
anymore so I I just it gets to a point
where it's like they have it but it
doesn't do anything they kind of ignore
the fact that it's there but in a way it
could provide a level of freedom and
security yeah I can do yeah and I'm not
saying that you have to use it and do
all those things but what it can do is
for me the way that I always look at
money and again I'm like financially
illiterate in terms of like investing in
all these types of things I didn't learn
how to do any of that kind of stuff I'm
like very intimidated by money I know
how to make it through creating content
and through creating comedy shows and
that kind of stuff I'm I'm good at that
but in terms of what to do with it when
I get it I have no [ __ ] clue yeah I
don't know either but which and I wish I
learned a lot more I don't but what what
I've noticed for me the relationship
with money has always been about Freedom
so it's like if I want to do the exact
type of Comedy that I want to do the
exact type of podcast I want to do if I
want to create if I want to outside just
creating if I want to live my life in
the exact way that I want to live yeah I
have to have a certain amount of it to
protect me in case everything goes wrong
right so I always looked at money as
like that's my freedom and if I get to a
certain amount of number like right here
I can do whatever I want when I want to
do it you have your number
yeah and that changes too see mine's in
mind
to me but but you're at your piece this
is your freedom yeah I feel good I feel
fine like I said when I [ __ ] you know
you would feel imprisoned by that money
yes yes yeah I probably feel imprisoned
by too much money exactly I'd be scared
of making too much money yeah because I
I would feel uh yeah I'm weird about it
yeah yeah 100 I've always I feel
imprisoned by not being able to do what
I want to do even if it's the smallest
thing I'm okay with not being able to do
what I don't know I know you are I know
you tell me I can't do something I
[ __ ] have look at this exactly that's
my point is like yeah you know we do our
show from a a shoe box in the valley but
yours
but my your Visions are very are very
Grand and you're able to execute the
visions and I'm one of those people
that's like I Just Want to Have Fun
and I hope they keep letting us have fun
I I think that there's a lot of people
that also think like this and I think
that's why it's really cool to hear this
perspective about how money can be scary
and how money can like put you in a
position of emotional instability where
I'm always coming from this place like I
don't I don't I don't want to be
associated with money I don't need to be
flexing I don't need to do all those
things but I love having it to know like
if everything goes wrong like I keep
money in case if everything goes wrong
that everybody here gets paid
everyone here everybody here gets paid
for
a while put it that way until until it
runs out yeah a while meaning I don't
touch it everybody gets here a year at
least
everybody gets paid so that's just my
way that's Freedom that's hey let's say
whatever the [ __ ] we want let's do
whatever the [ __ ] we want right let's go
to [ __ ] Africa let's just [ __ ] do
crazy [ __ ] and I want to do as much
crazy [ __ ] as I can before I die by
crazy it doesn't have to be dangerous
but it has to be let's go to Paris
dude I'm saying let's just do that and
be part of what a crazy adventure that
was no it's amazing and I I but I
recognize I need a little bit of
security but I'm a little bit more about
this but I'm more the other I like I
like I'm more like I'm more like uh uh I
like seeing it but I'm like I don't do
that yeah but I love it I love to watch
you guys do that [ __ ] yeah but I'm
always like man that's a world that I'm
not it's I never was built that way but
I like I like the piece there that yeah
I'm a little I am I but I do see what
you guys do sometimes and I'm always
like these [ __ ] are that's
living that's wild yep
but then I also go play golf near my
house and then that's fine for me too
yeah my little [ __ ] is fine for like
sometimes my little [ __ ] is good
enough also it also you're not at a
level where it's little it's like you
played a beautiful course
a huge success and it feels as if you
doing some you're doing something that a
lot of people especially in
entertainment but in life in general
don't do which go this is enough
people are miserable because they can't
go this is enough for your friends trust
me for happiness literally even though
you seem miserable but
to be brave about how more miserable he
would be exactly exactly and like I'll
be honest my relationship with money is
not like if I don't have it I'm not
happy that's not it my happiness comes
from freedom and I recognize that the
more freedom I have to do whatever I
want them happier I am but I love that
your happiness can potentially I imagine
come from just going I have enough I'm
so happy with what I have yeah I feel
pretty good I mean it was like it's like
again I've always said that if you
[ __ ] dotted me out and was like can
you do this forever and it never goes up
though you'll never make another day
yeah yeah I go okay because you're
having fun well because I'm blessed and
life is good and it's like there isn't a
moment where I go
at this stage in my life
I feel it feels good dude